Días, el Parlamento Europeo
concluye que en Cataluña
deben garantizarse los derechos de los alumnos
castellano parlantes
porque en la actualidad no se está cumpliendo
con la enseñanza obligada del 25% en castellano.
El partido socialista ha votado en contra de esa
resolución, mientras los independentistas consideran
que Tal dictamen es 1 pantomima
fruto de la persecución,
el victimismo que no nos sorprende, desde luego,
pero que tanto rédito les ha dado
y le sigue dando a los secesionistas.
El gobierno, recordarán,
ansioso de sus votos,
le compró eh al al independentismo el argumento
falad de que habían sido víctimas de 1 persecución
política con el pruses
y les ha regalado 1 amnistía
que hoy se está tramitando en el senado.
Y como son insaciables los independentistas,
pues las reclamaciones continúan
en el capítulo de hoy,
quieren la soberanía fiscal plena.
Traducido que ellos recaudan los impuestos
y darán a la caja común lo que consideren oportuno.
Suma y sigue.
Onda